Going to the extremes of racking,
this flat ribs stitch is amazing.
With your ribber set to pitch H
arrange the needles like this.
Notice all needles are and work
on the main bed and individual
needles are in work on the ribber.
And these will create the zigzag.
I've chosen to use every
fourth needle, but you can play
with different combinations.
Think of it this way.
We're putting decorative traveling
knit stitches on the face of
the purl side of the knitting.
Cast on with full needle rib,
then transfer the stitches
to your needle arrangement.
You'll cast on with the ribber set to H0.
When your cast on is complete, knit
one row from right to left, rack to H1.
Knit from left to right.
Rack to H2.
Knit from right to left.
To H3 knit from left to right.
You'll be racking to an even
number and then you'll knit left.
You'll rack to an odd number
and you'll knit right.
To complete the zigzag, continue
racking all the way to 10 and then
work your way back to zero and repeat
for the length of your knitting.
The secret of this stitch
pattern is the needle arrangement
and the extreme racking.